there's a wonderful quote it's escaping
me at the moment a great science fiction
writer I believe it was who said you
know you can't you can't allow your
manuscripts to to to gather destiny in a
dresser drawer
let's talk about marketing a screenplay
when does it happen
how important is it how does the
screenwriter do it effectively it's not
important it's essential it's crucial it
is life-affirming and it is absolutely
the responsibility of any talent any
creative to market themselves if it's a
writer and there's a script or a book or
some some some product time to market it
that's what you've got to do and here's
what most people don't understand it
should be and it is fun it's fun if I
take that same writer to a cocktail
party and I put a drink in their hand
and say tell these people they're
fascinated by you and what you do talk
about that they're gonna talk non-stop
they will you will not be able to shut
them up but if you on the other hand say
ah you've got a script you're at home
pick up the phone and call someone no
they don't want to do it suddenly
marketing is a negative it's a bad thing
it's all in how you perceive it
marketing and sharing your talent with
the world should be a joy it should be
your purpose the problem is people think
so narrowly 99.9% of writers who have a
screenplay ready to go to market they've
rewritten it it's ready they've tested
it beautiful what did they do they
automatically think I need to send it to
agents I need to send it to producers
and then they stop the thought ends oh
my gosh that does sound like not a lot
of fun because who are the people
getting all the scripts producers and
agents I would look at it and say let me
research this what are the kinds of
projects that are exciting that have
been produced successful projects that
people love that are similar over the
last handful of years whether it's TV
film or whatever
and I'll make a list and I'll do a
spreadsheet I'll list the
cinematographer in the editor and the
script supervisor in the casting
director and everybody but the producer
in the agent and I will start calling
them and reach out to their assistants
and saying I'm calling because oh my god
you guys were involved with one of the
favorite projects of all time I so
admire the work and I have something
spiritually very similar I'd love your
advice would you be my 5-minute mentor
would you play with me on this a little
bit there are endless conversations that
you can have you develop rapport with
people because you share a common
interest that's the key and if you can
get them interested in the conversation
then you can get them soon on the third
call interested in reading your script
they're not asking anything of them when
you call an agent you're asking them to
represent you that's a huge ask when you
send your script to approves your saying
will you produce this oh my god
that's the biggest ask of any because
what that means is that the press has to
invest several years of on their own
dime to create value and make this a
reality when you ask an agent to
represent your producer proves your film
you have to understand there's almost
nothing in it for them at the outset
they're going to invest their time and
their belief in their relationships on
your behalf for no money that's the
reality but if you make it about
something else if you make it about a
shared common interest that's exciting
and fun and those people can become your
ambassadors and backdoor that script
over to that agent or that script ever
it comes in a different package it comes
in a different context that's where
magic happens that's where alchemy kicks
in
I could talk about that for about three
days
you